Vous vous êtes déjà regardés dans un miroir ?
De très, très près...
Là, je vous promets que
vous pouvez vous faire peur.
Vous allez voir qu'il se passe
de drôles de choses sur notre peau.
Il y a même des monstres à
huit pattes qui se promènent.
Vous avez déjà entendu parler
des acariens ?
Ces toutes petites bêtes.
Ce sont des animaux microscopiques.
Enfin, des monstres plutôt !
Vous imaginez s'ils faisaient notre taille ?
Eh bien, certains vivent sur notre peau.
On les trouve principalement ici,
près du nez
ou au niveau des cils et des sourcils.
Là, ils sont installés à la base du poil,
dans ce que l'on appelle
le follicule pileux.
On estime qu'il peut y en avoir
plusieurs millions sur le visage.
Tenez, en ce moment, ça grouille
sur le mien et sur le vôtre aussi.
Quoi ? Mais c'est dégoûtant !
J'ai pas ça, moi ?!
Ces organismes appartiennent
à la classe des arachnides.
Ce sont donc des cousins
des araignées et des scorpions.
Mais impossible de les voir à l'œil nu.
Ces petites bêtes ne mesurent qu'entre
0,1 et 0,6 millimètres.
Pour les observer, on n'a donc pas le choix,
il faut un microscope.
Celui-ci grossit les objets jusqu'à 600 fois.
Alors, ça peut paraître énorme,
mais il en existe
de beaucoup plus puissants.
Les microscopes électroniques,
eux, peuvent grossir plus de 10000 fois.
Le plus puissant du monde
s'appelle Titan Krios.
Il se trouve à l'Institut Pasteur à Paris.
Il fait quatre mètres de hauteur
et permet une vision à l'échelle atomique.
Le mien est beaucoup plus modeste.
C'est un modèle tout à fait courant,
tout à fait abordable puisque, neuf,
il coûte entre 100 et 200€,
mais d'occasion,
celui-ci n'a coûté que 50€.
Mais revenons à nos acariens.
Pour les observer,
il faut d'abord les prélever.
Et pour cela, je vous conseille d'utiliser
du ruban adhésif.
J'en détache un petit morceau et je vais
le coller à l'extrémité du sourcil.
Là où les poils sont le moins résistants.
Ça fera moins mal au moment où je décollerai.
Ensuite, il faut être patient,
compter une bonne demi-heure.
Le mieux d'ailleurs,
c'est de chasser l'acarien
la nuit.
Il préfère sortir dans l'obscurité.
Vous collez le ruban adhésif
en début de nuit
et vous le retirez
au petit matin.
Voilà, je pense que c'est bon.
Je retire le ruban adhésif
délicatement.
Je dépose le scotch sur une lame.
Je glisse la lame sous la lentille.
Pour observer ce qu'il y a sur la lame,
il faut une source de lumière.
En général,
les microscopes en sont équipés, ou alors
ils possèdent un petit miroir
qui va permettre de capter
la lumière extérieure
ou bien celle d'une lampe.
Moi, j'en ai rajouté pour y voir
encore plus clair.
J'ai réussi à en piéger un
et en plus il bouge !
Vous avez vu ses petites pattes ?
Alors, il existe
de nombreuses espèces d'acariens.
Celui-ci est un demodex folliculorum.
Vous savez,
je vous ai dit qu'ils étaient installés
dans les follicules pileux.
Alors d'où viennent-ils ?
Eh bien, ils nous sont transmis
par notre mère juste après la naissance.
On y retourne.
On voit bien les quatre
paires de pattes
qui caractérisent les arachnides.
Puis, à l'extrémité
des pattes, des petites griffes.
Elles leur permettent de s'agripper
aux follicules pileux, justement.
En revanche, à cette échelle,
on ne peut malheureusement pas
voir que le corps est couvert d'écailles.
Elles leur permettent
un meilleur ancrage dans nos follicules
ou dans les pores de notre peau.
On voit bien la tête.
Et au bout de la tête, c'est la bouche.
Ils s'en servent
pour manger les cellules mortes de la peau
qui s'accumulent dans les follicules,
ainsi que le sébum.
Vous savez, le liquide huileux
qui est produit par nos glandes sébacées.
Vous voyez,
les acariens ne sont pas très beaux,
mais ils nous sont très utiles.
Et contrairement à certaines croyances,
leur présence sur notre peau n'a
rien à voir avec l'hygiène.
Ne cherchez surtout pas à vous frotter
frénétiquement le visage
pour les faire partir,
vous n'y arriverez pas. Les acariens
font partie de ce que l'on appelle
notre microbiote cutané,
et cela depuis des millions d'années.
Et croyez moi, ils sont bien accrochés.
Ils ne présentent pas non plus de danger
pour la santé.
Toutefois, les scientifiques pensent
qu'un surnombre de demodex
peut provoquer des démangeaisons
ou des rougeurs.
J'allais oublier :
quand les acariens sortent la nuit,
c'est pour manger,
mais aussi pour se reproduire.
Sous nos yeux ?!
Ça se fait pas !
Ça y est, je le vois !
Vous savez ce que je tiens
entre mes doigts ?
Un cheveu et ce n'est pas bien gros
un cheveu : entre 0,12 et 0,07 mm.
Alors, au toucher,
il a l'air parfaitement lisse.
Mais grâce au microscope, vous allez voir
que c'est une parfaite illusion.
Pour mieux observer, il en faut plusieurs.
Bah non, il n'en a plus !
Aïe !
Un, deux, trois.
J'espère que ça va suffire.
Ensuite, vous connaissez la mécanique :
on dépose les cheveux sur la lame
et ensuite on retient son souffle.
Un cheveu, ça ne pèse qu'un milligramme.
Il suffit d'un souffle pour qu'il s'envole.
Alors, pour qu'il reste bien en place,
on les recouvre avec une petite lamelle.
Ouf !
On est passé à un cheveu de la catastrophe !
Et ensuite,
on vient placer la lame sous le microscope.
Pas de geste brusque.
Lumière.
Et c'est parti !
Et quand on y regarde de plus près,
on voit que mon cheveu
ressemble un peu à un tronc d'arbre,
ou plutôt à une tige de palmier.
On voit des sortes d'écailles.
En réalité, ce ne sont pas des écailles,
mais des cellules qui se superposent,
comme les tuiles que l'on trouve
sur le toit de nos maisons.
Elles forment la couche
la plus externe du cheveu,
ce qu'on appelle la cuticule,
qui recouvre d'autres couches.
En fait, les couches sont disposées
de manière concentrique.
La cuticule recouvre
une première couche de cellules,
le cortex, qui recouvre à son tour
une autre couche nommée la médula.
C'est le cortex qui est responsable
de la couleur des cheveux
grâce à la présence plus ou moins grande
d'un pigment qu'on appelle
la mélanine.
Alors, un cheveu sain
comme le mien, c'est vraiment du solide.
A diamètre égal, il a une résistance
comparable à celle de certains métaux.
Tenez, lorsqu'on tire sur un cheveu,
il peut supporter un poids
d'environ 100 grammes.
Et maintenant, je vais vous montrer
à quoi ressemble un cheveu abîmé.
Mon coiffeur m'en a gentiment donné un :
un cheveu blanc
détérioré par le temps.
Contrairement à mon cheveu qui est sain,
celui-ci est éventré.
On peut voir nettement aussi
que des morceaux se décollent.
Puis son cortex et sa médula
se retrouvent à l'air libre.
C'est un peu comme si on avait coupé
le tronc d'un arbre en deux.
Malheureusement
pour le propriétaire de ce cheveu,
les écailles ne se remettront jamais
complètement en place.
Il faut les couper
et les laisser repousser.
Ça devrait suffire !
Je vais vous montrer ce qu'il se passe à
la surface de la peau quand on transpire.
Mais cette fois, je ne vais pas
utiliser le microscope, mais cet instrument.
C'est un endoscope, une petite caméra
placée au bout d'une tige.
On l'utilise en principe en médecine
pour voir l'intérieur du corps.
Mais là, on va diriger la caméra
vers la surface de ma peau,
à un endroit précis,
l'une des parties du corps
où, avec la paume et le front,
on transpire le plus : le bout des doigts.
Et ce que je vais vous montrer
est incroyable.
Vous voyez le bout de mes doigts ?
Apparemment, ils sont parfaitement secs
et pourtant
la peau y est couverte de sueur.
Ça ne se voit pas à l'œil nu,
ça ne se sent même pas au toucher.
Et pourtant,
je suis bien en train de transpirer.
Regardez,
on voit de petites perles d'eau
qui sortent.
C'est dingue !
Et si vous faites bien attention,
on peut même deviner les pores de ma peau.
Ce sont ces petits points.
On dirait même des petits cratères.
En moyenne, un humain sécrète
un litre de sueur par jour
quand il ne fait pas d'effort.
Mais lorsqu'on fait du sport,
de la corde à sauter par exemple,
ou en période de chaleur,
on peut perdre beaucoup plus : jusqu'à
8 litres d'eau dans une journée.
La transpiration est un mécanisme naturel
qui permet de réguler
la température corporelle
en la maintenant à 37 degrés.
Elle permet d'évacuer la chaleur
et de faire baisser
la température de l'organisme.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle la thermorégulation.
Le phénomène est intéressant.
J'en ai parlé
plusieurs fois dans les vidéos.
Ce n'est pas de l'eau chaude
qu'on évacue pour se refroidir,
la chaleur est évacuée
quand la sueur s'évapore.
Pour passer de l'état liquide
à l'état gazeux,
les petites gouttes de sueur que l'on a vues
pompent de l'énergie dans la peau,
de l'énergie sous forme de chaleur,
et c'est de cette manière
que nous régulons notre température
corporelle.
Voilà, j'espère que vous n'avez
pas eu trop de sueurs froides,
que ce voyage dans l'infiniment
petit vous a plu.
Surtout, n'hésitez pas à liker,
à nous dire ce que vous en avez pensé.
Je vous dis à dimanche prochain
chers épicurieuses et épicurieux
et d'ici là, portez-vous bien !